move over game of thrones get lost lost
we have another contender for worst
series finale ever now hold on before
you go clicking away at that dislike
button i have a few things i want to
make clear
stop it i actually liked pretty much the
whole season up until the end i mean
look at the episode by episode scores on
imdb they're fantastic and then
oh my god
so in this video we'll be taking a look
at dexter new blood's ending and where i
think it went off the rails and bonus
points if you can guess what moment in
the finale i thought everything
completely derailed i'll let you know
when we get there the final episode
titled sins of the father begins with
the aftermath of kurt caldwell's arson
attack on the morgan home in iron lake
new york kurt caldwell was this season's
serial killer antagonist who collected
runaways from his truck stop and turned
them into preserved corpses so they
would be kept safe from the trauma of
the outside world a trauma he'd witness
as a child when his father a truck
driver beat up prostitutes he'd bring
back to his rig ah the life on the road
i also found it a bit weird that kurt
kept offering jobs to these women and
many times throughout the season asked
the head waitress susan for applications
and yet she's never like hey all these
new waitresses keep going missing susan
could you uh get me one of those
applications anyway the last episode
isn't about kurt because he's caught and
killed by dexter and his son harrison in
episode 9. the main emotional threat of
this season has been the relationship
between dexter and his son as son he
abandoned 10 years ago after the events
of season 8. in one of the finale's
final scenes we see harrison pick up a
letter meant for his caregiver hannah
mckay who you may remember from seasons
7 and 8. this letter came into
harrison's possession after hannah's
death its contents leading him to
believe his father didn't die in a
hurricane those years ago but that he
had actually abandoned him and harrison
wants answers i wanted to look him in
the eye and ask him
how he could pretend like i didn't
[ __ ] exist over the course of the
season dexter struggles to tell his son
the truth that his abandonment wasn't
because he didn't love his son it was to
keep him safe from the monster he truly
is he's owed an explanation
but the only one is that his father is a
monster but when dexter finds his son
has the same dark tendency that he does
he comes clean believing it better he
teach him harry's code rather than let
the darkness take over for avid dexter
fans you'll know harry's code as a set
of guidelines for killing there are
about 12 of them in total but the two
most important especially for this
episode are one don't get caught and two
never kill an innocent iron lake was the
perfect place for dexter to hide out as
dexter says it's full of good people
since he only kills bad people it's an
ideal place for him to settle down it's
also why he and harrison need to leave i
know it's hard but we can't be ourselves
here
we can't do what we do if he's gonna
train harrison to follow harry's code
like some serial killer jedi they'll
need to be someplace where there are
lots of bad people so ideally he
suggests los angeles things this episode
start to get a bit weird when harrison
gives up leaving this new home so easily
the kid has been living at truck stops
foster homes skipping from town to town
and has finally found a family friends
and a seemingly perfect life and two
minutes later he's like can we get a
pool dexter also has a romance with
chief angela bishop who over the course
of the season has become increasingly
suspect that dexter who goes by the
alias jim lindsey is in fact the bay
harbour butcher of miami and nothing
says getting in the christmas spirit
then holding your lover at gunpoint and
bringing him to jail now let me know if
you guys picked this up but there's this
kind of weird moment where dexter almost
decides to grab this knife and stab her
first stupid idea she's a trained police
officer a few feet behind him and two
the consequences of killing her if it
were successful would break multiple
hairy codes and undoubtedly get him
caught but that isn't where i think
things go completely nuts dexter is
brought into questioning for the murder
of matt caldwell who in episode 1 dexter
killed when his dark side took over
breaking his 10-year no kill streak now
when he was caught at first i was like
man dexter's goose is cooked plus angela
has been in contact with lieutenant
angel batista of miami metro with
evidence she believes connects him to
the bay harbor murders but after
watching this scene over and over again
dexter is right all the evidence against
him is circumstantial even angela's
quote unquote proof that both he and the
bay harbor butcher used ketamine is
false we know from the original series
that dexter used a drug called a
torphine or m99 we also conveniently
never find out what secret evidence
marie laguerreta had evidence which
batista himself amounted to crazy
theories batista even ripped up the
warrants that lagarda had kept during
her investigation of dexter that would
have otherwise implicated him in the
murder of travis marshall the doomsday
killer from season six i also found it
super dumb when bautista says this to
angela chief bishop i hope i didn't give
you the wrong impression i'm a happily
married man when just five episodes ago
he hit on her at a police conference i
have a boyfriend can he handle you what
i'm trying to say with all this is if
dexter were actually put on trial for
either the bay harbor murders or matt
caldwell's he'd more than likely get
away with it especially mats considering
the mountain of suspicious evidence
pointing at kurt being his murderer kurt
lied about his son being alive had
motive for framing dexter burned down
dexter's home and even scrubbed his
entire serial killer motel 6 inspired
basement he used to imprison young women
but this isn't where things get unhinged
for me and if you guessed the moment i
thought everything went to [ __ ] was when
dexter kills logan from micelle that's a
bingo
that's a bingo first of all him just
killing logan from the cell is
far-fetched in and of itself but i have
re-watched this several times and still
don't know if logan was killed by a
bullet ricochet or by dexter cracking
his neck the bullet ricochet is just
crazy and lazy writing and dexter
choking a strong wrestling coach to
death also seems wild but it's not only
that that threw me it was how completely
out of character dexter is from here
until the end of the episode it's like i
was watching a completely different
dexter one who had to fit the ending the
writers wanted rather than the one we
spent nine seasons following so dexter
escapes and calls his son to meet him in
the forest at the very location where
the white buck was killed in episode 1.
i'm sure there's some metaphor for the
end of innocence here but come on
harrison almost stabbed a kid to death
for no reason at episode 4. and harrison
was almost ready to go with his dad and
flee town until he finds out that his
father killed logan he completely does a
180 to the point where he kills his own
father ironically with the rifle he got
from him as a christmas present what
really pissed me off about this was that
the reasoning of the characters here
didn't seem true to the characters that
were built up over the course of the
season dexter says to his son
there was no other way but there was
several in fact he could have done
nothing and let the investigation go on
he could have told angela the truth that
he hunted and killed serial killers
including the one who murdered her best
friend iris he could have confessed and
saved his son from living with the
trauma of killing his own father those
are just the ones i came up with off the
top of my head harrison also seems to
have forgotten his own words from
episode 9 that his father is responsible
for saving thousands of lives by killing
bad men
that means you've
saved like thousands of innocent people
yes killing logan was bad and against
the code but going from my dad is a hero
responsible for saving thousands to i
have to kill him because he screwed up
one time is a bit of a stretch so dexter
dies for giving his son
and this also releases the ghost of deb
who acted as dexter's foil to his inner
monologue but things take an even
weirder turn when angelo arrives and
lets harrison go not only that framing
it to look as if she were the one to
kill dexter i just feel like this is
such a dumb unnecessary option this
whole situation could easily have been
construed as harrison killing his father
in self-defense since his father clearly
went psycho and had just killed logan
and escaped custody harrison could have
theoretically gotten off scot-free and
might even have been able to live in
iron lake which he loved so much with
his girlfriend instead he's now back to
where he was at the beginning of the
season a transient with no home having
lost the one thing he was searching for
this whole time his father there's also
this whole setup of a potential
confrontation between dexter and batista
that we never get to see i mean it's
cold up there in new york but damn the
blue balls we also never really see how
the other townsfolk react to the fallout
of kurt and dexter being serial killers
and while i'm at it what was the point
of the rich billionaire was it just to
be a red herring because that dude could
have really shaken things up in the
story if he were more involved the most
tragic thing i actually thought about
this ending is that i was thoroughly
enjoying the season right until about
halfway through the final episode
showrunner clyde phillips has said he'd
be down to do a season 2 but no idea on
what that would look like with the
titular character being dead but what
did you think of dexter new blood's
ending am i totally off i want to hear
your thoughts in the comments thanks for
watching everyone please like and
subscribe and for more bad takes you can
follow me on twitter and instagram at
think story yt until next time remember
daddy loves you very much
you